der ast auf die erde zu und könnte sie
im nächsten jahrhundert treffen ein
einschlag wäre dramatisch mit einem
durchmesser von rund 500 metern hätte er
die bucht von 80.000 euro schirm bomben
es wäre absolut verheerend
jetzt hat die nasa zusammen mit dem
kernwaffen labor lawrence livermore
national laboratories das projekt emma
gestartet was es damit auf sich hat und
ob es die erde retten kann das jetzt den
klicks in science fiction herzlich
willkommen
am elften september 1999 wurde der
aktion benni entdeckt er ist einer von
unzähligen asteroiden die in unserem
sonnensystem
ja man muss sagen die hier so durch die
gegend fliegen vollkommen unkontrolliert
denn wo wie viele mit welcher flug bahn
unterwegs sind das ist weitestgehend
ungeklärt millionen und abermillionen
gesteinsbrocken rasen durch unser
sonnensystem und dabei sind die zahlen
allein für unseren planeten
beeindruckend es wird vermutet dass etwa
eine million us orden sich im bereich
der erdumlaufbahn befindet und die
gefahren die von ihnen ausgehen sind
größer als bekannt dass ein
himmelskörper in die atmosphäre
eindringt und explodiert oder einschlägt
kommt nämlich öfter vor als wir denken
wie oft das in den letzten 13 jahren
passiert ist wurde erst jüngst bekannt
wir haben darüber berichtet 26
asteroiden sind auf der erde
eingeschlagen in 13 jahren darauf
gekommen sind findige wissenschaftler
sie hatten die idee beim weltweiten
atomteststopp überwachungs netzwerk
nachzufragen ob es andere größere
explosionen auf der erde gab und es
waren 26 lediglich ein einziger
einschlag wurde dabei vorher gesehen
alle anderen kamen im wahrsten sinne des
wortes aus heiterem himmel
jedes jahr schlagen also im schnitt zwei
größere asteroiden hier auf der erde ein
bisher hatten wir großes glück denn die
gesteinsbrocken schlugen im meer in
wüsten oder sonstigen unbewohnten
gebieten ein und verdampften bereits in
der atmosphäre jetzt hat die nasa mit
der gezielten bahn verfolgung von
asteroiden begonnen im letzten jahr
startete ja die neue behörde planetary
die fans koordination diese haben die
usa eingerichtet um erdnahe asteroiden
zu entdecken und zu verfolgen sie gelten
als auslöser von massensterben auf der
erde alle paar millionen jahre steuert
mal ein größerer ast auf die erde zu der
das leben tatsächlich bedroht die nasa
hat deswegen das ziel bis 2020 alle
erdnahen asteroiden die größer sind als
140 meter zu entdecken denn genau diese
könnten der erde sehr gefährlich werden
experten plädieren deshalb immer wieder
für eine bessere weltweite
zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines
koordinierten frühwarnsystems und jetzt
will die nasa zum ersten mal gezielt die
flugbahn eines asteroiden beeinflussen
also endlich ist es soweit benny wirth
der erde zum ersten mal am 25 september
2001 135 nahe kommen dann ist das risiko
eines einschlags noch extrem gering
die wahrscheinlichkeit liegt dann bei
etwa eins zu 2700 aber wie wird die erde
dann die flugbahn beeinflussen sie
könnte der asteroiden noch näher an die
erdumlaufbahn heranbringen und damit das
risiko deutlich erhöhen
so weit wird es die nasa gar nicht
kommen lassen deshalb hat die nasa
zusammen mit dem kernwaffen labor
lawrence livermore national laboratory
das projekt hama gestartet helfer steht
für hyper locity asset mit ideation
mission for emergency response auf
deutsch hyper geschwindigkeit asteroiden
entschärfung mission für
notfallmaßnahmen es geht wirklich zum
ersten mal darum die flugbahn eines
asteroiden gezielt zu beeinflussen er
soll von der erde weg gebaut werden ein
neun meter langes raumfahrt soll auf dem
asteroiden einschlagen und ihn so von
seiner aktuellen flug- bahn- ablenken
allerdings so zeigen studien wären 71
schläge zur effektiven ablenkung nötig
und damit müssten 25 jahre vor einem
möglichen einschlag müsste damit
begonnen werden die physikerin megan
brasil ist an dem projekt beteiligt und
sie sagt dazu wenn viele abschlüsse für
eine erfolgreiche umleitung nötig sind
wird die mission schwieriger weil es bei
jedem einzelnen abschluss eine
fehlerquote gibt deshalb wird jetzt über
einen einzigen atomschlag gegen die raps
oliven nachgedacht der nukleare ansatz
hat das potenzial viel mehr energie auf
eine objekt wird wenn du zu übertragen
was die geschwindigkeit und flugbahn
stärker verändern würde so dass
kernwaffen labor das wäre viel
effektiver wahrscheinlich würde eine
einzige situation eben ausreichen die
allerdings nicht auf dem asteroiden
stattfinden würde sondern neben ihn wenn
er als erstes neues zum thema gefahren
durch asteroiden und zu allen anderen
dem erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen an
vom neuesten video und das garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion von pixum mitmachen und mehr
themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei
pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir
einfach hier draufklicken dann geht
alles quasi automatisch und natürlich
nicht das aber mit der genau glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken asteroiden
bedrohen die erde sz day ja ansonsten
würde ich mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran